an active volcano off the coast of north
africa is getting more dangerous this
morning reports from la palma and
spain's canary island say one side of
the volcano has just collapsed spain's
prime minister has pledged nearly 240
million dollars in aid and insists that
the island is still safe for tourists
dan johnson from our partners at the bbc
is on the palma right now
incredibly this eruption is now into a
third week and it keeps getting stronger
the volcano is producing even more lava
with even more force that's why all that
lava all that ash is pouring up into the
sky higher and higher and that means
more of a risk to a bigger area
the potential for more people to be
evacuated on top of the 6 000 or so who
have been out of their homes for a
fortnight now and i was talking to the
director of the canary islands volcano
institute who said he expects this
eruption to continue for at least
another 10 days potentially another two
months and even then when the volcanic
eruption stops when the lava stops
flowing that's not the end of the story
he said it could take years to recover
from this because there are vast lava
trails right across the landscape here
there are people still living here right
in the shadow of the volcano some of
them saying they've had enough now after
a fortnight of that thing thundering
rumbling right through their lives day
and night some have had enough they
can't get sleep they want to leave
someone making the decision to get to
safer places but then i've also spoken
to people who live with that volcano
effectively in their back garden who say
no as long as the authorities will let
me i'm going to stay i'm going to see it
out the unanswered question still is
when that eruption will actually cease
when the lava will stop flowing and when
the destruction will finally stop for
cbs mornings this is dan johnson bbc
news la palma